just here at the deal so must class I
don't want anyone to leave this program
without not only having the full
knowledge you don't ring up an agent or
put forward an offer never but also
having the exact steps you're not
usually remember you don't quite here
but you're not here ready to go to
implement and make this happen
it's one of the most satisfying parts of
my business I'm glad I'm glad you made
it past and don't stop do you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stay focused get ready now
ready now
stay focused get ready now for real get
ready now do say must class I'm gonna go
through exactly how I saw 256 nails in
one year and teach them honestly like
the exact steps hey how are you man is
that they loving it hey respect man
how's it going so good to see you yes
yes I was going to do like what comes
first the deal or the investor everyone
can do that
you've gone through it properly yet
[Applause]
where they like me going through that
I'm gonna do a really cool thing called
red amber green and you're gonna love it
then I'm gonna do beyond sales and then
I'm gonna do marketing
yes no no I gotta back in this seats but
you don't have to give me a big build up
just to welcome Samuel Lee yes yes flap
and the second day yes
I'm just backstage there's about 300
people there all very serious people
they're all advanced students and I'm
going to be going through step by step
how to package and sell a deal and then
Alastair after lunch is going to sell
the deals that they have found he's
gonna sell them live on stage so
everyone's excited I'm excited and I'm
feeling puffed ready to go had a workout
session this morning so I got my
endorphin release so I'm gonna smash it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much awesome has it been a
good a good day yesterday amazing man I
am so excited to be here I just cannot
resist coming down to these events so
you got me until lunchtime and honestly
deal sourcing is one of the most
lucrative in skills in the industry and
every time I've done a financial freedom
challenge you know you'll always say I
want to do rent to rent so I want to do
but I have to start with Dale sourcing
because that's what gives the initial
gets the initial funds in place so
fantastic industry so today I want to be
going through this morning like the
really actual right what do we do you
know I don't want you to anyone to to
leave this program without not only
having the full knowledge but also
having the exact steps ready to go to
implement and make this happen
yes because you yes probably cuz what
you know Conant you probably asked them
slightly wrong so you need to know the
game so they can't tell you what they
would accept okay they can't say so if
you say what would they accept they
can't tell you but when you know that
they can't give you the exact figure but
you just pile it up so you just say in
your language if you so if you say look
if I was to buy it you know if I was to
pull off for about five I mean what you
want what it didn't say they can't go
well we wouldn't this urge you need to
put it forward formally first like that
that that would be a weird thing for an
agent to say so and if they did say that
I'd just say yeah no prob listen I'm
just crunching numbers and stuff and I
don't want to waste time doing all my
spreadsheets in that if they're not
gonna drop a penny below I'm just so 85
is what I'm thinking
what do you work where we are right he's
being a reasonable human and not being a
major so but if you say to them what's
the lowest and except they will so they
cover that are across say or if you say
you know look he's on for 100 you know
I'm not falling off of 86 but first I
want to know if they're definitely
accept
they're also what we call tell you so
it's just the way you were which is this
whole you know relax look I'm thinking
about about 85 what do you reckon that's
safe tonight how do you put it how are
you saying it before I want to hit I
want to hear you do this on the phone
is there anyone okay probably you don't
know cuz the settings not right but
let's let's call that later okay I'm or
sit with you we'll see if you saying
anything wrong cuz I don't believe you
were saying that I think if you say look
I'm thinking about 85 you know what do
you think that to them that's kind of an
offer but because it's not then they'll
say yeah I thought that would be good
even if to put it forward
you just get theories this is this is
this is you're not you should remember
you're not quite here but you're not
here it doesn't in between stage and it
might take a bit practice I remember
thinking I said record yourself doing it
so when you when you're on the phone to
agents doing that having that record
yourself just put your foot you guys to
publish it but record it and then watch
it back and then you'll you'll learn a
lot doing them because sometimes it can
give it your ting on the phone you're
like and you speak Angela I think I'm a
well but it's hard to pinpoint what
happened because if you can just watch
it straight back you'll probably spot
yourself questions
and those did you find them on the
course or did you go away and implement
yes love that are they live now you make
you moan oh nice so how much you from
from just those is it to do Jeter dad
for Leos how much what's your average
expected income off of those for
interment deals property in two thousand
a Memphis course and that's fifty
percent occupancy which is probably
conservative for Cardiff two grand a
month
thank you you're awesome why do guys
all right did you get that did you get
that funny when it happens because I
just tell people to walk with me and it
speeds what's your favorite cause to run
my favorite course honestly I just don't
know it depends on the course cuz I like
the exciting coaching into a program cos
off there's no content I'll just turn up
and see what see what's going on but
then there's also always a danger in
doing that that it will be rubbish
because but it never is so it's a bit
more a bit more apprehensive yeah so I
mean the deal selling masterclass is
good because it's just like that's my
thing man something else of people that
watch more YouTube videos they kind of
almost restricted because they got found
in them but maybe their partner who they
love with all their heart he's really
skeptical don't go to the crash course
you know don't you know it's a pipe
dream and usually a partner that says
that it's actually trying to protect you
and they do want the best for you of
course they do otherwise they wouldn't
be with you and as it's Valentine's Day
today I thought I'd give some
relationship advice
meaning what are you reckon what do you
reckon hello man how you doing
absolutely excellent how are you my
friend
wonderful thanks very much nice one
what's your ETA about how I don't know
probably 5 10 minutes oh wow I'm gonna
be there in about about half an hour but
when you get there you're gonna be
welcomed with love Mary warmth and hugs
and kisses from like rustle and angst
the team but just bear with me a little
bit cuz I yeah I'm just a little caught
but I'll be there very soon I'm
literally driving man
delighted to have you on the channel we
want to pick your brain we want to know
what's happened since then you've been
very successful in deal sourcing you've
got some really cool stuff going on as
well which is only just recently been so
that's so that's in it so as we stand
today
90 about 1909 and how much how much
profit then once you've paid for the HMO
management company which you need i do
you need okay once you've paid the HTML
manager and bills can touch everything
how much profit between seven and eight
hundred quid okay month which is which
is good but it's happy it's hands off
and that's what I want now because deal
sauce is become my main my main things
it work the gray hairs ask me and ask me
into
mr. foon they gonna finish so I would in
my mind it's roughly two to sue a knife
grant to get into a lease option to get
all your solicitors to do all all of
that kind of stuff it's about two to two
and a friend so if someone gave me 20
grand today I will try and get 10 lease
option agreements because 10 lease
option agreements at two three four five
hundred pound profit Aman ya is gonna be
two three four five thousand pound a
month almost completely passively
assuming that you then pay ten fifteen
percent for a manager so you see in the
Euro so let you have it on and we have
to keep pausing it for him to jump you
just like okay see thank you so much for
coming out to London
welcome to with us on a Wednesday every
single week we have success students you
qualify success tune but we've got it
all fixed for a few random tenants so
that's great I mean a lot of people
would say all the properties off the
market is gone now okay
whereas you said oh it's off the market
has he actually resolved can I speak so
like Porsche and I think that's a great
lesson in how you need to be as property
investor you need to be someone that
rather than just stopping and I don't
know actually continues to portion
that's something that we do practically
yeah I think what talked to me the
figures then so you bought it for 169
what for 169 I'm gonna get
Thank You Think's things about beautiful
so two really interesting conversations
and a Glenn Kirkham I was a long link
open we always talk about best for an
hour and a half
it's I'm just gonna I think we was going
to put that out the raw it was such an
interesting conversation
Steve fast half an hour great guy
it's just so it's so amazing to see
variable stories and that's also really
why do I do it so I love these days of
filming and bringing people into the
studio in their stories I'm tired now
but I've got one more normal meeting
it's a technical website meeting which
I'm constantly looking forward to
because I'm feeling a bit tired but what
movie in then I'm gonna get back out now
I think you've really I've really
enjoyed that we enjoyed chatting with
those guys it's one of the most
satisfying parts of my business is just
having people in there succeeded
chatting to them picking their brains
what's been your favorite part of that
Crowley yeah
oh you enjoy video on the toilet now I
wasn't a human but I just love traveling
yeah even here in the back seat or in
slowly okay so now I've been out 12
hours
personal training session in the morning
meeting meeting meeting filming filming
speaking and now it's 6 p.m. final
meeting of the day with my man RAF wraps
the internet genius advertising video
man and Amelia who just makes my life so
much easier every capacity I don't think
I want to film it today because this is
techy this is boring so glad you can
just clear off and we're gonna call it a
wrap and I'll be driving home in a
narrow side piece at and you remember me
[Music]
[Music]